[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER: On
Monday, we talked
about financial
technology as a whole,
and what we're going to do
in these next four classes
is really talk about
three major technologies.
The broad subject of artificial
intelligence, machine learning,
and deep learning,
we'll talk about today,
and next Monday, we'll move on
and talk about the marketing
channels, what I'll broadly
call OpenAPI and some
of those conversational agents
and the relationship that
is happening there.
And then next Wednesday's
class, I might be off.
It's the following
Monday's class,
we'll talk about blockchain
technology and cryptocurrency.
So we're taking three
big slices of technology,
and then we're going
to go into the sectors.
And so what I thought of about
in structuring this class,
as we've already discussed,
is I take a broad view
of what the subject of fintech
is, that it's technologies
of our time that are potentially
materially affecting finance.
So in any decade,
any five year, it
might be different technologies.
It's technologies of a certain
time that are materially
affecting finance,
and it's the broad--
any competitor can use fintech.
Now, I recognize
that a lot of people
use the subject or fintech,
and they narrow it down,
and they just use those
terms for the disruptors,
the startups.
And there were
really good questions
of why I think of
it more broadly.
I just think that the incumbents
are very much involved
in this fintech
wave, and to ignore
that would be at your peril if
you're starting a new business,
if you're an entrepreneur.
And of course, if you're Jamie
Dimon running JPMorgan Chase,
or you're running a big
bank in China or in Europe,
you would be at your peril
if you didn't think about it.
And big tech, of course,
has found their way in here.
The Alibaba example's in China,
but all around the globe,
whether it's Brazil,
whether it's India,
whether it's-- your big tech
has found their way in here.
And so I've also decided
to sort of structure it
around these three big
thematic technologies,
and then we'll start to dive
into the sectors themselves
and take a look at
four or five sectors
before we call it a day at
the end of the half semester.
So I'm about to pull up
some slides, but, Romain,
are there any broad questions?
ROMAIN: Nothing so far, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: OK, thank you.
So just give me a
second to make sure
I pull up the right
set of slides.
I think that-- all right,
so two readings today.
I don't know if you were
able to take a look at them.
I hope you had the time
to take a look at them.
And these were
really just a chance
to sort of grab hold of a broad
discussion of what's going on.
Again, I went to the
Financial Stability Board.
It's a little dated
because it's 2017,
but I thought the
executive summaries
and these various
sections were helpful.
And then a shorter medium
post really on six examples,
and today, we're
going to talk about
what is artificial intelligence,
what is machine learning
and deep learning, and then what
are the eight or 10 major areas
in finance that it's being used.
And then next
Monday, we're going
to talk about a lot
of the challenges
and go a little deeper
with regard to this.
Now, I said that I
had study questions.
We're going to see if
we can get this to work,
and I'm going to ask for
volunteers to speak up.
If not, Romain might
just unmute everybody,
and then we'll see who I can
cold call on or something.
But who would like
to take a crack?
And remember, we're all
pass emergency and no credit
emergency, so this
is just about trying
to get the conversation going.
But who would want to
answer the question, what
is artificial intelligence,
machine learning, deep
learning?
And you don't need to
be a computer scientist,
but these terms are
really important
if you're going to be an
entrepreneur and do a startup,
or if you're going to be in
a big incumbent or big tech
company, just to have
this conceptual framework
and understanding of artificial
intelligence, machine
learning, and deep learning.
So I'm going to wait for
Romain to either find
somebody who's raised their
blue hand, or, Romain, you
get to help me cold
call if you wish.
But hopefully, somebody
wants to just dive into this.
ROMAIN: I'm still waiting
let's see who will be-- ah,
we have our first
volunteer of the day.
Thank you, Michael.
GARY GENSLER: Michael.
STUDENT: Sorry, I
forgot to unmute.
So my understanding-- artificial
intelligence just is more
of an over encompassing
term, being--
just computer is kind of
mimicking human behavior
and thought, so that's more--
GARY GENSLER: Let's pause there.
And a very good
answer, so computers
mimicking human behavior.
And, Michael, just a sense--
do you have a sense of how--
when did this come about?
Was this in the last
five years, or was it
a longer time ago that
somebody came up with this term
"artificial intelligence?"
STUDENT: More like the
early to mid 1900s.
It's been a while.
GARY GENSLER: So
it's been a while.
It's actually way
back in the 1950s,
"artificial
intelligence--" the concept
of a computer mimicking humans.
In fact, at MIT, we have the
Computer Science and Artificial
Intelligence Lab.
It's not a creature
that was just invented
in the 20-teens or 20-naughts.
It goes back decades.
It was a merger of
two earlier labs,
but we've had an artificial
intelligence lab at MIT
for multiple decades.
So who wants to say what
machine learning is?
Romain?
I hand it off you
to find another--
ROMAIN: Who will be the
next volunteer for today?
STUDENT: I think the
machine [INAUDIBLE],,
there's very limited or even
no intervention with human,
and learning are you
solve problems step
by step in a sequential manner.
So that is like
the machine solve
problems step by step without
much intervention by humans.
GARY GENSLER: So I
think you're raising
two points, is the
machine solving
a problem without
intervention, which is good.
And then you said
briefly, learning.
Do you want to say
something more,
or anybody want to
say, what does it mean
that the machine is learning?
ROMAIN: We have Rakan
who raised his hand.
STUDENT: Yes, well,
essentially, it
means that you're
feeding the machine data,
and as you feed
the machine data,
the machine learns not
to do specific tasks.
And you get better
results as you feed
it more data and more and more.
GARY GENSLER: All right, so the
concept of machine learning,
again, is not that new.
It was first written about
in the 1980s and 1990s.
It had a little bit of a wave--
you might call it a boomlet,
a little bit of a hype cycle--
and then it sort of tamped down.
But the conceptual framework
is that the computer, machines,
with data, are actually
learning, that they actually--
whatever algorithms or decision
making or pattern recognition
that they have gets better.
So machine learning is a subset
of artificial intelligence.
Artificial intelligence
is this concept
of computers, a
form of machines,
mimicking human intelligence,
but it could mimic it
without learning.
It could just replicate or
automate what we are doing.
Machine learning
was a new concept--
it didn't take off.
It didn't dramatically
change our lives at first--
where, actually, the
computers could adapt
and change based upon
analysis of the data,
and that their algorithms
and their pattern recognition
could shift.
Does anybody want to take
a crack at deep learning?
ROMAIN: Anyone?
Albert raised his hand.
STUDENT: So deep
learning involves
using large neural networks
to perform machine learning,
so it's sort of a subset
of machine learning.
But it can be very powerful,
and most of the time,
it just gets better and better
as you feed it more data.
Other machine
learning algorithms
tend to have sort of a plateau
and can't improve no matter
how much data you feed them.
GARY GENSLER: So important
concept there in a phrase
was "neural networks."
Think of our brain's--
neural, neurology.
It's about our brains.
Early computer
scientists started
to think can we learn something
from how the human brain
works, which is in essence, a
biological computer that takes
electrical pulses and
stores data, analyzes data,
recognizes patterns.
Even all of us right
now are recognizing
voice and visual patterns.
That's in our human brain.
So when looking at the brain,
the conceptual framework
is could we build a network
similar to the brain,
and thus, using these
words, neural networks.
In deep learning and
machine learning,
there's pattern recognition,
but deep learning
is a subset of machine
learning that has
multiple layers of connections.
And in machine learning, you
can take a base layer of data
and try to find patterns,
but deep learning
finds patterns in the patterns.
And you can think of it as
putting it through layers.
Now, if you're in Sloan,
and you're deeply involved
in computer science, and
you also enjoy the topic,
you can go much further.
But in this class, we're
not trying to go there.
The importance of deep learning
is that it can find and extract
patterns even better
than machine learning,
but it takes more computational
power and often more data.
Deep learning is more an
innovation of the 20-teens,
and by 2011 and 2012, it really
started to change things.
And in the last
eight years, we've
seen dramatic advancements
even in deep learning.
It's a conceptual framework
of taking a pool of data,
looking at its patterns,
and going a little higher.
I'm going to talk about
an example a little bit
later in this
discussion, but please
bring me back to talk about deep
learning in facial recognition,
deep learning in
autonomous vehicles
and just thinking
about it there,
and then we'll pull
it back to finance.
ROMAIN: Gary?
GARY GENSLER: Yes, questions?
ROMAIN: We have two questions--
one from Rosana, who's asking,
what is the difference
between representation
learning and deep learning?
And then we'll give
the floor to Pablo.
GARY GENSLER: So
very good question.
Representation learning,
you can think almost as
in between machine
learning and deep learning.
If we said, this is almost
like those Russian dolls.
The AI is the big vessel.
Machine learning is a
subset, and deep learning
was a subset of
machine learning.
Representational learning is
a subset, in this context,
of machine learning, and it's
basically extracting features.
So think of machine learning
that's looking for patterns.
It's extracting
features out of data.
So photo recognition, our
standard Facebook photo
recognition that might
recognize Kelly versus Romain
is extracting certain
features of Kelly's face.
I'm sorry if I'm
picking on you Kelly.
You just happen to
be on my screen.
But it's extracting
features, so some people
call it feature learning or
representational learning,
but extracting features as
opposed to specific data.
And then deep
learning is generally
thought of as a subset
even though there
is some debate as to how
you would categorize these.
And you said there
was another question?
STUDENT: Yeah, hi, Gary.
This is Pablo.
So I just wanted to verify,
because my understanding
is that, also, one of the big
differences between machine
learning and deep learning,
or artificial intelligence
in general besides
deep learning,
is that deep learning
used unstructured data,
whereas typically, for
machine learning models,
you need basically tables of
data that you have organized
and labeled and everything.
And just the check
whether that's
the difference besides
the additional complexity
and multiple layers.
GARY GENSLER: So let
me step back and share
the important vocabulary,
and again this
is important vocabulary
well beyond being a computer
scientist.
It's important vocabulary if
you're running a business,
and you're trying to get the
most out of data and your data
analytics team.
So I'm going to assume we're
talking as if you are now going
to be in a C-suite, and you
want to get the most out
of your data analytics
teams and so forth--
is this concept of structured
data versus unstructured data,
and then I'll go to
that specific question.
Data that we see all the time
with our eyes, that we read,
that comes into
us, you can think
of as unstructured
sometimes because it
doesn't have a label on it.
But if it has a label
on it, all of a sudden,
people call it structured data.
So machine learning,
conceptually,
is that the machines are getting
better at recognizing patterns.
It's primarily about
pattern recognition,
that the machines are getting
better recognizing patterns off
of the data.
And the question here
is, is machine learning
always structured learning?
And structured learning
means that the data
is labeled, that you
have a whole data set,
and it's labeled.
An example of labeling
I will give you,
that we all live with in our
daily lives-- how many people--
just use the blue
hands if you wish.
How many people have ever
been asked in a computer,
will you please
look at this picture
and tell us whether
there are any traffic
lights in the picture?
We want to make sure
you're not a robot.
All right, so here,
I'm just going to--
Romain, just cold call somebody
that put their hand up.
I want to ask them a question.
ROMAIN: Sophia, please?
GARY GENSLER: All right,
Sophia, are you are unmuted?
STUDENT: Yes I'm on.
GARY GENSLER: All right,
so, Sophia, when you go in,
and you tell the
computer that you're
not a machine, why do you think
they ask you that question?
STUDENT: To make sure that
there aren't any bots who
are trying to take
advantage of any service
that the machine
is trying to offer.
GARY GENSLER:
Really good answer.
You're correct, but you're
not completely correct.
What's the other
reason that they're
asking you whether that's
a traffic light or not?
STUDENT: And also
to collect data
so that they can use
that data for labeling
for future purposes as well.
GARY GENSLER: So they
are labeling data.
They're using Sophia, if I
might say, as free labor.
Sophia is training the data
that Google or whomever
is putting together there.
And thank you, Sofia.
You're labeling that data
so that autonomous vehicles
will work better in the future.
You're also frankly
labeling data
to put millions of people
out of jobs as truckers,
but I don't want
you to get sort of
wrapped up into those sort
of social and public policy
debates, but that's
what's happening.
So back to the earlier question.
Data can be labeled by us.
An earlier form of
labeling was labeling
what is an A, what is
a B, what is a C, what
are all the letters
of the alphabet
so that our postal
services now can
use a form of machine learning
to read all of our written
scratch on envelopes.
If we address an
envelope, it can all
be read by computers
rather than humans.
To your earlier question--
I went a long way around
this, but machine learning
can be both unstructured
and structured.
The question was, is machine
learning always labeled?
Is machine learning
always structured?
And the answer's no.
Machine learning can also be
unstructured and unlabeled.
Deep learning can be
both labeled, which
is structured, or unlabeled.
Some of the economics and
some of the computer science
are worthwhile to understand.
Labeled data can
be trained faster.
Label data can, in many regards,
lower your error rates faster
and have a certain--
extract correlations better,
but it comes with a cost.
You need to label the
data, and so there's
some tradeoff of getting Sophia
to label data or other humans
to label data versus
unlabeled data.
Think about radiology in
the practice of medicine,
and looking at body
scans or mammograms
or any form of
radiology to identify
whether there's an anomaly.
There's something that needs
to have further investigation
to see whether it's
a tumor or not.
Radiology is dramatically
changing in the last three
or five years based upon machine
learning and deep learning.
Remember, deep
learning just means
there's multiple layers
of pattern recognition
in these neural networks.
Labeled radiology, labeled
mammograms, or labeled
MRIs will train the
machines faster,
but unstructured, unlabeled
data can also be used.
You need bigger data sets.
So I went I went
off a little bit,
but I hope that that's helpful.
Other questions, Romain?
ROMAIN: Yes, we have
one from Victor.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
STUDENT: Hi, professor.
I just wanted to
double click on the--
take a step back in the initial
definitions between machine
learning and deep learning,
because we were discussing
that deep learning had
the feature that it
keeps learning despite the
data growing exponentially.
It doesn't plateau.
But I don't fully understood
the differentiation between two
concepts beyond that.
GARY GENSLER: So I
didn't disagree or agree
with that comment,
and I apologize,
I can't remember who said
that deep learning keeps
to grow exponentially.
I think both machine
learning and deep learning--
both machine learning and
deep learning learn from data,
and this word "learn" should
be explored a little bit more.
What machine learning
and deep learning can do
is extract correlations.
I hope nearly
everybody in this class
has taken some
form of statistics
at some point in time.
You might have hated
statistics, but we all took it,
and some of us took
more advanced statistics
where you use linear
algebra and the like.
But just thinking about a
standard regression analysis--
a standard regression
analysis finds a pattern,
generally a linear pattern,
or a quadratic pattern
if you move on.
Machine learning and deep
learning find pattern,
and they're really remarkable
tools to extract correlations.
And one of the features
of both machine learning
and deep learning is
they look at error rates,
particularly versus data
sets that have been labeled.
And traditionally, what you do
is you have a big data set--
maybe it's millions of pieces
of data that you're training on,
and you take a
random sample of it
and put it to the side, a
random sample on the side
that you label.
And then you compare
what comes out
of the machine learning with
the test data on the side
and see what's the error rate.
And this labeled set on this
side might say, these are men,
these are women,
this is a stoplight,
this is a traffic light,
whatever the labeled data is,
and you see the predictive
model, what's the error rate.
Both machine learning
and deep learning
continue to do quite well.
And I apologize I cannot
remember who said it earlier,
which student said, deep
learning continues to grow
further than machine learning.
It can, but I wouldn't accept
that machine learning can't get
better and lower error rates.
Now, once you get down
to very low error rates,
that's another
circumstance altogether.
The difference between deep
learning and machine learning
is that--
I'm going to use photo
recognition software.
If you put a photograph into a
computer, where does it start?
Does anybody-- what does it
see at the very beginning,
it's base level of data?
STUDENT: The pixel?
GARY GENSLER: What did I hear?
STUDENT: I said, the pixels.
GARY GENSLER: Pixels.
So the only thing a
computer can read is pixels.
It has to start with
the pixels and build up,
and the next layer at most--
and again, I once
pretended to know something
about computer science.
But I programmed in
Fortran and APL years ago,
and that was before
many of you were born.
But I guess I used to know
how to program something.
But if you read the
pixels, the next layer
up to find a pattern
in the pixels
is just small changes
of shade, and then
you can think of the next
layer up from those little--
you can see edges.
So the computer has to
sort of go through layers
from the pixels up to this is
a traffic light versus a stop
sign, and so deep learning
interposes multiple layers
of pattern recognition.
Some would say that
you need many layers,
and then other research
shows that, no,
once you get to
about three layers,
there's less and
less return on this.
So let me sort of--
unless, Romain, is there
other questions, or can I--
ROMAIN: No, we're all good.
GARY GENSLER: All
right, so again, this
is just a broad
thing, and we're not
going to spend as much time.
But what's natural
language processing?
Does anybody want to--
just what are these
words broadly mean?
ROMAIN: Any volunteers?
GARY GENSLER: I'll
volunteer, then.
So natural language
processing is just
simply taking human
language, natural language,
and processing it down
to computer language,
all the way down to
machine readable code,
or going the other direction.
So you can almost think
of it as input and output
to the computer, or we
have many, many languages
represented on this call right
here with 99 participants.
You can think about
it as translating
French to German and
German to French,
but instead it's
natural language, what
we do, down to the computer.
And this is really important
in terms of user interface
and user experiences, and we'll
get to that a little bit more.
And then we're going to talk
a lot about which sectors
in financial services
are being most affected
at this point in time.
So I won't call on the class
right now because I want
to keep moving to go forward.
So we're in to talk about the
financial world and fintech,
and then-- oops, I
didn't change this.
This slide will-- I'll
shift, because that's
from the other day.
So we looked at this
slide the other day,
and it just helps us--
what is AI machine learning?
Extracting useful
patterns from the data,
using neural networks
that we talked about,
optimizing to lower error rates.
Optimizing so that you actually
say with 99% or 99 1/2%
of the time, this is a traffic
light, this is a stop sign.
Actually optimizing.
There's lots of programs
that you can use.
Google has TensorFlow, and--
I don't know.
Have many of you
ever used TensorFlow?
I don't know all of
your backgrounds,
but any show blue hands?
I'm not going to call
on you to describe it.
I'm just kind of curious
if there's many people that
have used TensorFlow or not.
ROMAIN: How about
we go with Devin?
GARY GENSLER: So Devin's
actually used it.
I wasn't going to
pick on them up,
but if you wanted to say
anything about it, Devin.
STUDENT: Yeah, I
can very briefly.
So it essentially gives
like a plug-and-play method
to do machine learning and
build neural nets in Python.
You don't necessarily have
to have a full understanding
of how under the hood works.
You can just add bits as
you want, take bits away
as you want, and it speeds
up the whole process.
GARY GENSLER: And so what's
important about that is,
just as somebody that
came of age in the 1970s
and '80s didn't have to learn
how to computer code all
the way down to
machine readable code,
they could learn how to use--
by the 1990s, C++, or C
And C++, and later, Python.
And many people in this
class know how to use Python.
In the machine
learning area, there's
been plug and play
programs like TensorFlow,
where you don't need
to actually know
how to build the data
and things like that.
Most importantly,
and this is if you're
thinking about
being a data analyst
or actually building
a business around it,
it's the data and the questions
you train on the data.
And most studies have
shown, as of 2019,
that 90%, 95% of the
cost of data analytics
is what some people might
call cleaning up the data,
making sure the
data's well labeled.
We talked about structured
versus unstructured data
earlier.
Really important about
that labeling, the cost.
If you have 1,000 people working
in a machine learning shop,
or 500 people or five,
it is quite likely
that a big bulk of their time
is standardizing the data, so
to speak cleaning up the data,
making sure that the fields are
filled, and ensuring that you
can then train on this data,
meaning it's labeled, or
enough of it's labeled.
And then thinking about what
the questions you're really
trying to achieve, what
you're trying to extract.
Why is it happening now?
This is off of Lex Freeman's
slide again, but why?
Because the hardware, the
tools, the analytics-- a lot
has shifted in the last
five or eight years.
To give you a sense of what it's
being used for, all of these,
we know.
We know already.
It's dramatically
changing our lives.
When we're sitting at
home, sheltering at a home,
and you're thinking
about the next movie,
and you're on Netflix,
Netflix is telling us
what they think the next
thing we should watch.
That's training off of
not just the knowledge
of what each of us
has been watching,
but it's about what
others are watching.
It's the Postal
Service that no longer
has to have a human
reading the text,
our scrawl on the envelope.
It's Facebook with the facial
recognition programs and so
forth, and autonomous
vehicles that
are now being
tested on the roads
but are very likely
part of our future.
Now, will they be rolled out in
a dramatic way in five years,
or will it be 15 years?
But I would feel
comfortable that we
will have autonomous
vehicles on the road
sometime at least by the
2030, but maybe others
would be more optimistic.
So it's changing a lot
in many, many fields.
The question is now, how is it
shifting this field of finance?
Why do I put it at the center
of what we're doing here?
So we talked about this.
This was just my little
attempt, and so now you
have a slide that does what
we chatted about before.
One important thing also is
happening is, in finance--
[CLEARING HIS THROAT]
excuse me--
people are grabbing alternative
data, using alternative data.
I said earlier that the
most important questions
are what's the good data?
So then we think about, in
finance, what type of data
do we want to grab?
Data analytics in finance
goes back centuries.
That is not new.
The Medicis, when
they had to figure out
to whom to land
in Renaissance era
had to figure out who
is a good credit or not.
And two data scientists from
Stanford started a company
called Fair Isaac--
those were their last
names, Fair and Isaac--
and that became the FICO
company, the Fair Isaac
Company.
So the data analytics in
finance and the consumer side
has certainly been around
since the 1950s and 1960s,
but where we are
now is to say what
is the additional types of
data that we might take,
and not just banking and
checking and so forth?
But Alibaba can look at a
company, look at a company
very closely, and do a full
cash flow underwriting.
Alibaba, because
they have AliPay,
can see what that small
business is spending
and what that small
business is receiving.
Amazon Prime can't
quite do it as much,
but they can do a
bit of it as well.
And even Toast, which
is a fintech company
in the restaurant business
until this Corona shut down,
Toast could see a
lot about what's
happening restaurant by
restaurant in their cash flows.
They had the revenue side more
than the expenditure side.
Alibaba, much better
data sets than Toast,
but I wouldn't put at rest
a Toast started earlier
in the last year to do credit
extension to the restaurant
business.
Now, do you need deep
learning and machine learning
to do that?
Not necessarily.
You can still use
plain old regression
and linear statistics,
linear regression analysis,
but machine learning and deep
learning help you go further.
And then there's, of
course, everything
about our usage, our browser
history, our email receipts,
and so forth.
If we look at China,
they've stood up
a broader social credit
system, and in that system,
they can tap into
data about users
in many different platforms.
Romain, do I see--
are you waving at me?
Is there a question?
ROMAIN: No, I'm not.
Sorry for that.
GARY GENSLER: That's all right.
So natural language
processing, I mentioned.
I just want to say a
few more words about it.
Think of it as computers input
and output interpretation.
This sort of going
from German to French,
or going from computer language
to human language and back
again.
That's this important
back and forth,
and so it's natural
language understanding,
meaning a computer understands
something, and also
natural language generation.
So it can be audio,
image, video,
any form of communication--
even a gesture.
This hand wave can
be interpreted--
if not now in 2020, within a
few years will be interpreted.
A movement of your face
will be interpreted as well.
And so how it's being used
is really quite interesting,
but we all know about chat bots
and voice assistance already.
That's shifting our worlds.
Yeah?
ROMAIN: We have a
question from Nadia.
GARY GENSLER: Nadia, please.
STUDENT: I have one question
related to the chat bots.
What kind of
factors do you think
will encourage people
to use chat bots?
Because now, I do
think people prefer
to talk to a person
rather than chat bots.
GARY GENSLER: Well,
I think, Nadia,
we might still prefer
to talk to a person,
but there's a certain
efficiency in--
and I'm just going to stay
in finance for a minute.
But there's a certain efficiency
that financial service firms
find that they can use chat
bots instead of putting
a human on the phone.
So even when you and I call
up to a Bank of America,
and we want to check in on
something on our credit cards,
we're put through a
various series of push one
if you want this, push
two if you want that,
and we're pushing buttons.
That's not high
technology, by the way,
but that's an efficiency
that Bank of America
has interposed into the
system instead of having
a call center of humans.
And so if they can move
from a cost center of humans
to an automated call
center of chat bots,
they can provide services at a
lower cost and to more people.
Now, you and I might still
want a human on the other side,
but business is
interposing an automation,
and that automation means,
often, quicker response time.
So many of us, you go
into a website today,
and there's a little bot
window that comes up.
And the first thing that
comes up on so many websites--
and this is true if
it's a financial site.
It's true if it's a
commercial website where
you're buying something online.
It's probably true
of dating websites,
that there's some little bot
window that comes up and says,
can we help you.
That's not a human, but it
does give us greater service.
It gives us an immediate
recognition somebody's
answering a question.
Nadia, do I sense you'd
prefer not to have
the chat bots interposed?
Is Nadia still there?
STUDENT: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, because I do
think sometimes,
chat bots, we ask a
question, but their answer
is not really related
to our questions.
GARY GENSLER: So you
would prefer a human
because you think the human
will interpret your question
and be able to answer it better?
STUDENT: Yes.
GARY GENSLER: So if the chat
bot could answer as well
as Kelly could answer--
again, I'm sorry, Kelly.
You're on my screen.
But if the chat bot could answer
as well as Kelly or Camillo
or others in this
class could answer,
you'd be all right with that?
STUDENT: Yeah, it's faster.
GARY GENSLER: See,
if it's faster,
and it can answer as well.
So those are some of the
commercial challenges.
ROMAIN: I think Ivy would
like to contribute as well.
GARY GENSLER: Sure.
STUDENT: Yeah, I just wanted
to offer a little bit of some
of the consumer
studies that we did
when I was working
for a startup where
we were building chat bot.
And interesting enough, I
think most people are actually
pretty--
and we did a pretty
large survey,
and most people were
pretty open to the idea
of working with a chat
bot because I think
that's become so pervasive.
But then there's
this idea, they want
to know that it is a chat
bot, that the company is very
transparent about that,
because people change
their behavior when they
are speaking to the chat
bot or some kind of
virtual assistant,
as long as they know,
just to build that trust.
And also, I guess
we try to be more
explicit in our
wording, both verbally
as well as written texts.
And then secondly,
I think because--
I guess I wanted to pose
this as a question, too.
When I think about chat
bots and things like that,
the technology is not
necessarily there,
or it takes a long time.
And so I'm just curious what
your thoughts are in terms of--
for me, I see it as like AI
gets us 80% of the way there,
but we need the human
touch 20% of the way there.
And so I actually see a lot
of companies either having
that human at the end of the--
you ultimately still need a
human at the end of the day.
So I mean, I just wanted
to explore that a little.
GARY GENSLER: I think what
Nadia and Ivy are raising,
and I'm sure we're all
grappling with this.
We are living in a
very exciting time,
and I'm not talking
about this corona crisis.
That's a different
type of challenge.
But we're living
in an exciting time
where we can automate a lot of
things that humans have done.
We've automated so
many things that humans
have done for
centuries, but we're now
automating this
interface, through chat
bots and conversational
interfaces, voice assistance.
I would dare say that, of the
90-plus people in this class
now, that most of us, if not all
of us, at some point in time,
have used Siri.
I mean, if we're
driving along a highway,
and we're supposed
to be hands free,
we might talk and start up
an app or something legally,
legally.
And there's a lot of
automation that's going on.
How many of us have called
to arrange a reservation
at a restaurant, and
we're not quite sure
if we're talking to a human
or a conversational agent?
But I think that
what Ivy's saying
is that there might always need
to be a human somewhere there.
I don't know, Ivy,
if that's correct.
That's where we are in 2020.
Let's think about
autonomous vehicles.
Right now, we're not
comfortable enough.
The manufacturers aren't
The computer scientist
aren't comfortable enough.
The regulators aren't
comfortable enough.
The public's not
comfortable enough
to have autonomous vehicles
on the road with no humans
whatsoever, but that's
not really necessarily
where we'll be in 2030.
Or take radiology.
Right now, at least
in advanced economies
like in Europe and
the US and elsewhere,
in advanced economies,
we say we still
want a doctor's eyes on
a radiologist report.
So the mammogram might be read
by some artificial intelligence
machine learning trained data,
but we still have a human.
But is that really the tradeoff
we'll make in a few years?
And is it the right
tradeoff to be
made in less developed
countries, where
they don't have the resources
to have the doctors?
And now, we even look in
the middle of this crisis,
the corona crisis, if--
this is sort of God willing.
If the Baidus of China
and the Googles of the US
and others sharp
analytic AI shops
come up with a way to
extract patterns and develop
some recognition as to
who's most vulnerable,
are we going to rely
on that, or are we
going to say a human has to also
interpret it and be involved
in it?
And I don't know.
So I think we're
at an exciting time
where we're automating
more and more.
I do agree with you,
Ivy, there's always
going to be a role for humans.
I'm not terribly worried that
we'll all be put out of a job.
200 years ago, our ancestors,
all of our ancestors,
were, by and large,
working on farms.
That's the economies.
And we have found other
things to fill those roles
and those needs.
I think we'll still have the
humans, but not in every task.
So let me go through
a little bit--
so the Financial
Stability Board, this is
their definitions
I'm going to pass on,
but this was in that
paper that you all
read about what big data
and machine learning was.
When I show this page
to computer scientists,
when I show it to
colleagues of mine at MIT
from the College of
Computing, they look at it,
and they say, jeez,
that's funny that a bunch
of financial
treasury secretaries
and central bankers
and their staffs
define big data machine
learning this way.
So I partly put
it up because this
is kind of what the regulators
define as to what it is.
Machine learning may be defined
as a method of designing
sequence of actions to solve a
problem, known as algorithms,
and so forth.
Computer scientists would name
it a little bit differently.
So I said to you
the other day that I
think of financial technology
as history is building
on these things, but machine
learning and deep learning
is at this top level.
In the customer interface,
it's the chat box
we were just talking about, and
on the risk management side,
it's extracting patterns to
make better risk decisions.
So it's in these
two broad fields,
I sort of think of it is
the customer interface
and then lowering risk
and extracting patterns.
And sometimes, it's
not just lowering risk.
It's enhancing returns.
And so I was going to
go through and chat
about each of these
eight areas, and not
all of the areas we're going
to talk about are as robust.
Asset management, right now--
asset management from
hedge funds all the way
to the BlackRock and Fidelity
are exploring the use
of machine learning and AI.
By and large, most high
frequency trading shops,
most hedge funds today,
most asset managers today,
are not using much
machine learning and AI.
I view that as an
opportunity in the 2020s.
I view that as a real
possibility of a shift, a very
significant shift.
But where is it
being used so far?
So BlackRock has been
announcing and saying
that they're already
using BlackRock
as one of the world's, if
not the world's, largest
asset manager.
Before this corona crisis,
probably $6 or $7 trillion
of assets.
It's, of course, a
lower number now.
And BlackRock and
others have been
saying we're using machine
learning to actually listen
to all of the audio files,
all of the audio files
of the major companies
when they announce
their quarterly earnings.
And they're also putting in
news articles, digital news
or articles about
those announcements,
and also feeding in some of
the actual financial statements
that are released.
And that takes a little bit of
natural language processing.
You need some form of
taking the audio files,
taking the written files,
and interpreting that.
But with that data they're
looking for sentiment.
They're trying to
interpret the sentiments
and see if the stock
price are moving
based on all of that data.
Now, that's BlackRock with
$6 or $7 trillion of assets.
They're deeply resourced,
fidelity, and so forth.
But if you go down
the value chain,
if you go down to
smaller asset managers,
they're not doing a
lot, I would say, yet.
But there are hedge funds
that are specifically saying,
we are data analytic
hedge funds.
We want to move
a little further.
We want to try to use this
machine learning because it's
a better way to
extract correlations,
and that's what
it's looking for.
It's pattern recognition.
I think that you're going
to see more and more high
frequency trading shops and
hedge funds exploring this.
But one conversation I had
in the last couple of months
with the high frequency
trading shop--
and it was a shop that
had about 100 employees.
It was not big, but
it was big enough.
It was certainly making
money in those days.
I don't know how it's doing now.
But they said, look, we feel
pretty good about what we do,
and when we look for
algorithms, when we look--
our algorithmic trading doesn't
need all of that expenditure
and all that resource
intensive thing of machine
learning and cleaning up the
data and finding the patterns.
And in fact, we think that is
not flexible enough yet for us.
We're looking for short
term opportunities,
and we think that regression
analysis and our classic linear
and correlation analyses
are enough at this moment.
What's going to come in
2023 is a different thing,
but what they're doing now,
[INAUDIBLE] not really needed.
Questions about asset
management just before I
go to a couple other fields?
ROMAIN: Now is the time to
raise your hand if you have any.
I don't see any, Gary.
GARY GENSLER: So cost--
STUDENT: Sorry, Gary, I
raised it in the last second,
so Romain didn't see it.
GARY GENSLER: [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT: My question is--
so I fully understand
their claims
that this is not the claims
of the asset manager,
you were talking of
high speed trading.
I don't see why machine
learning or any algorithm
besides linear regression
doesn't have enough flexibility
to actually replicate
what they're doing,
but with a bit more of
accuracy or computing
performance, et cetera,
because in the end,
my understanding is
that you need the same--
except when you go
to deep learning.
But you need the
same data sources
that you currently have, and
the only thing that you're
going to do is, instead of just
having linear models predicting
the different traits
that you want to do,
you have other
models that can find
alternative basically
trends and et cetera.
So I don't see the
limitation there of using it.
GARY GENSLER: So I think you
raise a really good point.
We're in a period of transition.
I personally don't think
that machine learning
and deep learning is the
answer to all these pattern
recognition
challenges in finance.
But you will find I'm more to
the sort of center maximalist
than center minimalist,
and those of you
that know me, that when we talk
about blockchain technology,
you'll find I'm more to
the center minimalist side.
But what I mean by that is
I think that the pattern
recognition out of deep
learning, machine learning--
and by pattern recognition I
mean the ability to extract,
with remarkable ability,
correlations and then create
certain decision sets based
on those correlations--
is better than classic linear
algebra, classic regression
analysis.
But it comes with a cost, and
that's the tradeoff in 2020.
Maybe in a handful of
years, it'll be less cost,
but I'm going to use
an example, which
is not about asset management,
but it's about lending.
I had this conversation just
a few weeks ago with the CEO
of a major peer to
peer lending company,
and as this is
being recorded, I'm
just going to maybe
not say his name.
And I said, do you use
machine learning and deep
learning to do your
credit decisions,
all your credit decisions?
And he said, yes, we use
a lot of alternative data.
We run it into
the decision sets,
and we see what patterns emerge.
And I said, so you extend
credit then based on that?
He said, well, not exactly.
He said, what we do is,
we look for patterns,
and then when we find
them, we then just
use classic algebra and linear
flagging when we actually
extend the credit.
So we use it to
look for patterns,
but then we sort of use the
traditional way, and I ask why.
He said, well,
there's two reasons.
It's less costly than running
the whole thing all the time,
and two, they can explain
it better to regulators,
and they can explain it
better to the public.
And at least in
consumer finance,
there were laws passed about
50 years ago-- in the US,
it's called the Fair
Credit Reporting Act.
These laws were
passed and said if you
deny somebody credit you
have to be able to explain
why you're denying them credit.
And of course, there are other
laws in many other countries
similar to that,
and there are also
laws about avoiding biases.
In our country, we call it
the Equal Credit Opportunity
Act or ECOA, and
in other countries,
similar things about
avoiding biases
for gender and race and
background and the like.
So I'm just saying that,
whether it's asset management,
whether it's consumer
credit, there's
some tradeoffs of these
new data analytic tools.
And those tradeoffs, I think,
in the next handful of years,
will keep tipping in the way
towards using deep learning.
But they don't come--
they're not cost free
is what I'm saying.
ROMAIN: Jos has his hand up.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
STUDENT: So you
talked a bit about how
this is impacting the high
frequency trading shops.
Is there something
similar happening
on more like value investing
long term or in the hedge
funds?
So I heard some of them
are using satellite image
to predict the number of cars--
to see the number
of cars [INAUDIBLE]
and predict the sales for
that year, things like that.
But I don't know, do you see a
lot of headroom in this area?
GARY GENSLER: I think there
is headroom where I'm saying,
I've mentioned two areas,
but I think you're right.
There's a third area.
The two areas are
sentiment analysis, just
sentiment analysis around
either an individual company
or the overall
markets and seeing
what the sentiment, the
mood, the sense of the crowd
is off of words,
images, or the like.
And then also the
high frequency traders
and so forth just looking for
the patterns in the short term
trading.
You're talking about more on
the broader value orientation,
and I absolutely share
your view that we'll
see more of that develop.
I haven't heard a lot of it,
but you're right about sector
after sector that you
might be able to analyze.
But again, it has
to have some ability
to extract a pattern better
than classic linear regressions
in analysis.
So let me just try to hit
a couple more of these
because we're going
to run out of time,
but we are going to talk
Monday more about these.
We talked about call centers,
chat bots, robo-advising,
and so forth, so I
think you've got that.
A lot of that is
not just efficiency,
but it's also inclusion.
You can cover many,
many more people
by automating some
of these tasks.
It's just reality,
it's the tradeoff
of efficiency and inclusion,
that you cover far more people.
You can also be more targeted.
You can be more targeted
with advice and so forth
as these are automated.
It comes with the tradeoff
that Ivy and Nadia
were talking about earlier.
Credit and insurance--
this is the concept
of basically how you
allocate or extend
or price, either alone
or price insurance.
To date, the insurance companies
and insurance underwriting
are starting to grapple with
this, starting to move on,
and we'll talk about
some fintech companies
in this space.
I think that insurance companies
have been a little bit slower
to do it than, let's
say, the credit card
companies, but the allocation--
I think this will be
dramatically shifting.
I think if you look at
what's going on, again,
in consumer credit and small
business credit in China,
through WeChat Pay
and AliPay, they're
much further along than we
are, frankly, here in the US.
We're still largely reliant on
a 30 or 40-year-old architecture
around the Fair Isaac
Company, the FICO scores
that are used in about 30
countries around the globe.
These are still quite
limited, but FICO itself,
FICO itself rolls out
new versions of FICO
every few years.
I think they're rolling
out FICO 10.0 this summer,
or were before
the corona crisis.
I think, if you look at
the end of the 2020s,
either FICO will
not exist at all,
or FICO 14.0 or 15.0
will look a lot more
like a machine learning,
deep learning type of model.
What it is right now
is pretty rudimentary
compared to what it could
be in 5 or 10 years.
This is an area that's
being used a lot--
fraud detection and prevention.
The credit card
companies, if you
look at Cap 1 and Bank of
America, Discover, American
Express, they're deeply now
using machine learning tools
for fraud detection.
Many of us probably remember
just a year or two ago,
you would still call up
your credit card company,
and you would say I'm
traveling to France,
I'm traveling to Italy,
wherever I'm traveling.
I want to put a
flag on there that I
might be using my cell phone--
using my credit card in
one of these countries.
Well, most companies
now don't ask you
to put a travel alert on it.
Now, part of that
is because they
know where we're traveling
because we're walking around
with these location devices.
The banks no longer need us
to call them to tell them
we're going to be in
Paris because they
know we're in Paris--
this location tracking
company device.
But in addition to
that location device,
they are also using
machine learning
to do fraud detection and
prevention in the credit card
space.
Similarly, they're
using it to track
and try to comply with laws
called anti money laundering.
These two areas, fraud detection
and any money laundering,
which I might call
compliance broadly,
are two of the areas most
developed right now in 2020.
That doesn't mean they'll
be the most developed later.
I think a lot more will happen
in the underwriting space.
A lot more will happen in
the asset management space.
Robotic process
automation-- I want
to just pause for a minute.
Does anybody have a sense of
what these three words together
mean-- robotic
process automation?
Romain, you get to see if
there's any blue hands up.
ROMAIN: Andrea.
STUDENT: Hi.
So robotic process
automation is very simple.
You have a lot of
manual processes
or manual work done
in, for example,
back office of the banks.
And the idea here
is, instead of people
doing that, low skilled
work or workforce,
you can actually teach robots
or the algorithms with the PC
to do it instead of you.
So for example,
it can be anything
as simple as just
going through the forms
and copying or
overwriting and rewriting
some of the words or parts of
the forms to some other place.
GARY GENSLER: Right.
So robotic process
automation can be as simple
as you're giving your
permission to a startup
company, a fintech company,
to access your bank account.
And one of us gives a fintech
company-- maybe Credit Karma.
We give Credit Karma the
right to go in and look
at a bank account of ours.
Credit Karma might not have
permission from Bank of America
go in, but they have my--
I'm permissioned them.
I've given them my password
and my user ID, and they go in,
and they want to automate.
Credit Karma wants to automate.
They don't want to have a human
actually have to type that all
in.
It can be as simple as just
automating inserting the user
name and the password
and the like,
but then you go further than
it can navigate the web page.
It can navigate and
click the right buttons
and get the right
data and so forth.
So robotic process
automation can
be helping a startup
company say Gary Gensler,
we want you as a
client of Credit Karma.
We, Credit Karma,
will figure out
how to interface
with Bank of America
and with Chase and the others.
But also, the banks are using
robotic process automation
to automate so much of their
both back office and their data
entry.
And one form, just
to say, is many
of us now feel very
comfortable to deposit
a check from our cell phone.
So you can take your cell phone,
take a picture of a check,
and somehow, that
gives an instruction,
a digital instruction,
to move money.
Well, part of that's
natural language processing,
that the cell phone could take
a picture, read all that data,
put it into computer language,
and actually move a digital.
Part of that is robotic
process automation.
Romain, was there a question?
I think I saw some
flashing chat rooms.
ROMAIN: Yes, sorry.
You have 15 minutes left.
GARY GENSLER: Oh, OK.
Then was there a question or no?
ROMAIN: No question
at this point.
GARY GENSLER: So now, trading--
trading is an area I spent a
lot of time with Goldman Sachs.
And in that trading
of the day, we
were automating everything
we could automate,
and this is in the 1990s.
And ever since, anything is--
a trading floor in 2020 looks
very different than a trading
floor in the 1990s in terms
of the day to day trading,
and this is trading at
the center of the markets,
the platforms themselves, and
of course, the high frequency
traders on the other
end of the market
is basically just
like asset management.
What patterns can you see?
Now, this is less
about value investing.
This is the patterns
right in the nanoseconds
and milliseconds and so forth.
I'll make one note in terms
of trading, which is not
related to machine
learning, but just related
to the corona crisis that
we are all living in.
I have an overall belief
that this coronavirus
crisis will accentuate trends
that we've already seen.
In industry after industry,
if we're locked down
for two, three, or four months,
or God forbid, for 18 or 24
months--
if we're locked
down for that long,
we're going to find
new ways to engage
with each other in
economic activity
and social activity
and the like.
And we've already had
some trends, deep trends--
we talked about them Monday--
that we're unlikely to be using
many paper money and coinage
money.
Three months from now,
nearly 70% or 80% the world
will have forgotten how to
use paper money and coinage.
In fact, it will even be viewed
as a disease delivery device.
It might be dirty.
It might be something
we don't want to use
because it could be a problem.
Well, let me talk about
trading for a second.
The New York Stock Exchange
and the world's largest stock
exchanges are now electronic.
They could have done
that two years ago.
When the Intercontinental
Exchange,
which is a big public company,
bought the New York Stock
Exchange a handful of years
ago, five or so years ago,
Jeff Sprecher, the
entrepreneur who
started the Intercontinental
Exchange in 1998 or '99,
he's always been an
entrepreneur, an innovator,
to do electronic trading.
They could have taken the
New York Stock Exchange fully
electronic, but guess what?
That's what happened in
the last three weeks.
So after we get out of
this lockdown period,
will we bring back the floor
of these London and New
York and Shanghai and
Mumbai and so forth?
Will we bring back the floors?
I think quite possibly not.
Not sure, but there's a lot
that's shifting on, I think.
Natural language
processing-- we talked
about in customer service,
process automation,
and sentiment analysis.
These are sort of the
slices that I think about
in these fields.
So I was curious how many
people have ever used Siri?
Probably almost every
hand would go up.
But how many people
have ever used Erica?
ROMAIN: So perhaps we
have Shaheryar who'd
like to share his experience.
Sorry for your name--
mispronouncing it.
STUDENT: Yeah, so it's
essentially like Siri,
but you actually-- it's a
product of Bank of America,
and you can use it to
check your spending habits.
You can also use it to, if
you need things with regards
to check depositing, or if
you want to know something,
it can do that.
But currently, I believe
it's not as refined as Siri,
and I still think there
is a lot room over there
for improvement.
GARY GENSLER: Why do you
think it is that Erica--
and JP Morgan has one as well.
I can't remember
what her name is.
They all do seem to be
mostly female voices,
if I'm not mistaken.
But why is it that
Erica and the like,
a virtual assistant, as
they're called in finance,
aren't as developed as the
Siris and Alexas, do you think?
STUDENT: Sorry, can you
repeat the question?
GARY GENSLER:
Anybody can answer.
Why is it that the finance
virtual assistants like Erica
are not yet as fully developed
as the Home and other ones
like Siri and Alexa?
STUDENT: I believe some of--
I think it's got something
to do with the fact
that the number of users
for financial assistance
is way lower as compared
to Alexa, Siri, or Alexa
or whatever.
So I believe that is something
which may explain it,
the disparity between these
two kinds of assistants.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
Any other thoughts
on that, one why--
ROMAIN: Nikhil has a different
take, and that we have Laira.
STUDENT: Probably along
similar lines, banks so far,
the interactions probably have
been in person or over phones,
and they weren't used to
processing data and processing
requests.
I think they have
a smaller data set
to go through and understand
what problem customer
questions are.
And that's probably a limiting
factor versus, say, Siri,
they have much more
data on everyday users.
I think that's probably
the biggest differentiator.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah, and was
there another comment, Romain,
you said?
Sure.
ROMAIN: So I think
Laira had her hand up,
but I think she withdrew it.
So perhaps we can
hear from Brian.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
STUDENT: So in
addition to the data,
I think there's also a
human capital element.
It's possible that Apple
has better human capital
capabilities than do these
financial institutions,
so it's harnessing
that data as well.
GARY GENSLER: Yeah.
So what we've just
talked about was data,
human capital, experience--
all true.
Also, Erica and
the financial firms
only started more
recently, and so forth.
But the voice recognition
programs and then
taking that data that an
Apple has or their competitors
in big tech around the globe--
because it's not
just here in the US--
is really remarkable now.
Even to the extent
that I don't know
how many people use earbuds,
but if you look closely
at the user agreement on the
airbuds that you use, it says--
and if it's an Apple,
if I'm mistaken,
the Apple lawyers will chase me.
But the user agreement
says that they
can listen to that to
help you to make sure
that there's not a drop
between your earbuds
and your cell phone.
They are picking up vast amounts
of data, vast amounts of data
from our text messaging.
If you look at
something like Google,
they're picking it up from
Google Chrome, Google Maps,
Gmail.
Multiple places that
they can pick up,
and we talked about this
conceptually, big tech
versus big finance versus
startups in this triangle
of competitive landscape.
And why I wanted to sort of
close on Bank of America Erica
and this discussion
of Erica versus Siri
and Alexa is big tech using
Google, just as an example,
has this remarkable network that
they're layering activities.
Remember, we said data
network activities--
that's the Bank of International
Settlement way to put it,
and what a perfect
example to show.
Google has Gmail.
It has Maps.
It has Google Chrome.
It has Android, the
operating system.
So all of these different
ways to build their network,
and they layer
activities on top of it,
and then vast amounts
of data come in
and the human capital that was
mentioned at the end there.
And they have more experience
to move it forward.
Apple, similarly.
Baidu and Alibaba in China
and so forth, similarly.
If I were a CEO of
a big incumbent,
yes, I would be very focused
on the fintech startups, but I
tell you--
I'd be looking at
big tech in a way
that their advantages are
really significant, very
significant advantages.
Romain, I see some
hands up maybe.
ROMAIN: We now have Laira
who has her hand up.
STUDENT: Yeah, I'm just curious
to know what do you think?
So currently, we know that tech
has kind of-- or AI has kind of
emerged to the financial
and payment space
in the form of
virtual assistants,
but what do you anticipate the
next step would be in terms
of this integration
of technology and AI
into the payment space?
What next after the
virtual assistants?
GARY GENSLER: We're going to
have a whole class on payments
specifically, but
I think that what's
happening in the
payment space is
we've seen specialized
payment service providers.
Of course, we've seen a
lot of the competition
starting with PayPal in 1998.
This is not a new
space for disruption.
But what we've
seen more recently
is, in the retail space, whether
it's companies I've mentioned
earlier, like Toast, that
got into one vertical,
one slice within payments,
which was restaurants--
they can provide a better
product for that slice.
And then can collect back
to AI enough robust data
within that slice--
this is using Toast
as an example--
that they can provide better
software, better hardware,
and also less risk loans.
Basically, as Toast
started to provide lending
to restaurants within that
space, built upon the payment.
So it's the marriage between
the user experience providing
the users--
in that case, the restaurants
in the payment space--
but providing the users
in that space something
that the generalized platform--
a bank payment system
is generalized.
It's multi sector.
It's a general
product, and Toast
was able to say, no, we
can provide something
that just restaurants--
there might be something
a little unique
about the restaurant
business that we can
provide software and hardware.
In their case, it was tablets.
They were providing
tablets for the servers
to walk around and
take the orders.
They could integrate the menu
right into the payment app.
So there was something a
little bit unique about that.
But then based on that,
they get a bunch of data,
and that data helps
them with, I would say,
underwriting
decisions based on--
it doesn't have to
be machine learning.
But it's enhanced data analytics
because of machine learning.
So I hope that helps.
I think on the
conversational agents
and the virtual assistants,
what we're seeing in the payment
space, because that
was your question,
is we're moving from
card authorized payments
to mobile app QR codes.
Then the QR codes is not
based upon virtual assistants,
but it's an interesting
question whether we'll
get to some voice
authenticated payments.
There are a lot of uses of
voice authentication already.
Vanguard and many
other asset managers,
where you can have your
brokerage accounts,
you can call in and
get voice authenticated
before you can do a trade.
And that voice
authentication is just
like other forms
of authentication,
but it's not perfect
as of this moment.